spring is here and many of you are
getting ready to host friends and family
for Easter and all of us are thinking
about spring cleaning so we can deep
clean our homes and tackle the dirt dust
and pollens that trigger our Springtime
allergies well there is a solution
Zerorez and joining us to tell us more
our owners Ben and Doug McKee welcome
back you guys this is a messy carpet and
we're going to show you the zero res
difference in just a minute but I was
just talking to you guys about allergies
they're getting bad right now and zero
arrest can actually help with that we
can't eat you gotta understand Mercedes
your carpet at your home or at your
business is the largest air filter so
it's collecting all the dust pollen
dander and all those nasty things
floating around in the air and getting
your carpets professionally clean is a
great way to reset that filter so that
it not only looks good but it actually
goes back to filtering the air yeah if
you just are going with Aesthetics and
how it looks the zero res difference is
amazing especially if you are someone
like me who has white carpet when you
guys come in it looks brand new and it's
all because of your Zero Water tell us a
little bit about that yeah so our
technology we clean carpets unlike
anybody else out there traditional
carpet cleaning methods are actually
detrimental to your carpet's health
they'll cause rapid resoiling and it's
because traditionally carpet cleaners
use soap zero res we don't leave any
soap residue behind we're not putting
any surfactants in your carpet you're
left with clean carpets like they came
from the factory let's see Zero resin
action and while we are watching I love
this this is my favorite part the one
swipe that we do just to see the zero
res difference it's incredible you can
see right away the difference but you
gotta understand this is your water it
acts like a soap without any of the
residue left behind this water is heated
up to about 230 degrees at our truck
mount it's hooked up to a 300 horsepower
vacuum so we're deep fitting your
carpets and we're getting it nearly dry
when we're finished and you guys just
won best of Las Vegas again correct
again yeah I'm I lost count of how many
years but it's because you know we've
been in Las Vegas for nearly 20 years
Doug started us out of his garage and
we're just we're a family-owned business
and we want to make sure that our
customers have a great experience and
we're here to create raving fans and get
your home cleaned up I noticed that the
second someone comes into my home from
Zerorez always so nice respectful
special for us tell us what you're going
to give away we do right now you can get
your carpets cleaned as low as 35
dollars per room plus we're going to
throw in a hallway absolutely free
minimum Supply but take advantage of the
deal absolutely thank you again to zero
rest look at that for sponsoring this
segment check out their spring cleaning
special of the month carpets clean for
as low as 35 dollars per room plus get
that hallway cleaned free call
702-840-333 or go online
zerorezlasvegas.com for more minimum
Supply
we'll be right back